[Music]
6 42 tomorrow The Fast and Furious
experience comes to life at the Las
Vegas Motor Speedway yeah first time
ever for fuel Fest here in town offering
the chance at the right of a lifetime in
our Candace Charles I know she's put the
helmet on but she is the Las Vegas Motor
Speedway boy all kinds of stuff out
there even celebrities tell us all about
it Candace
well it's all about the hot rods and
good times here at the Las Vegas Motor
Speedway on Saturday October 22nd you
guys can check out hot rods Jets I like
this one one of the Exotic custom cars
it'll be more than 600 for you guys to
check out via drifting car experience
live performances just a great good time
for folks who are into the Fast and
Furious experience and I have a guy who
knows a little bit about that of course
the co-founder of fuel Fest Cody Walker
thank you so much for joining me this
morning those people can expect from
this first time Las Vegas experience a
bunch hundreds of incredible cars uh
we've got a drift competition live music
awesome sponsor exhibits uh special
guest appearances it's it's like there's
something here for everybody on Saturday
it's going to be a great show and I love
that this is also for a great cause as
well partial proceeds go to the
non-profit that's really brother Paul
Walker started tell us a little bit
about that nonprofit yeah it's called
Reach Out worldwide we're very proud of
it it's a piece of quality left behind
and they help out families uh people
after severe weather and natural
disasters here at home and abroad and uh
We've we've contributed over two hundred
thousand dollars for charity at this
point through the fuel Fest show so
that's and that's due in part from all
of the fans and all the supporters that
come to the show so really grateful for
that awesome awesome thank you so much
Cody for sharing that with me of course
we got talked to whether the car and
this is supported of course and he is an
iconic guy because he's a great content
creator you guys can check him out on
Tick Tock Instagram Facebook all the
above Kaden thank you so much for
joining us this is your this is the whip
this is the car right tell me a little
bit about it uh so this is a 93 Nissan
Skyline uh it's an r33 I imported it
from Japan about last year around around
New Year's and had it ever since uh put
a really little fast and furious style
wrap on it that's kind of what I grew up
with grew up watching and stuff like
that so that's kind of the look I was
going for now I know you mentioned
that's what can you guys believe that
he's only 19 years old and he already
has this whole experience going congrats
man that's so awesome you mentioned that
the back is kind of the huge highlight
why yeah so you know you got the you saw
it over with the R35 over here the four
circular tail lights that's kind of the
the perfect shot for the skyline you
know that's the most recognizable part I
think the kind of iconic iconic backside
right there awesome awesome what's up
look it's gonna be a great experience
thank you Caden thank you Cody
appreciate you for coming out this early
you guys can enjoy all of these cars and
so many more uh this Saturday October
22nd starting at two o'clock it goes to
nine of course I got you covered with
all the details with tickets and
everything all of that on 8newsnow.com
for now live from the Las Vegas Motor
Speedway I'm Candace Charles 8 News Now